wer bei shanghai
schon heute wo wir morgen sind wir
morgen wieder als neubeginn
servus sagen bei uns zum halo und auf
wiedersehen sagen so wie die berliner
aussagen würden wir sind hier in einer
echten bayerischen wald in kneipen jetzt
erklären wir euch ein bisschen bayerisch
deutsch spanisch genau ich hoffe freude
eigentlich grüße euch alle ich grüße
euch gelöst werden jetzt hier an hunger
und jetzt werden wir erst mal rollt
bewerbenden für discos lassen es im
schwarzwald
weiß man dass ich mit weißwurstessen
freunde es ist ein weißwurst mit haut
ich wollte sie mal
die haut muss natürlich wächst und dann
süßen
jetzt nicht nur den schafen das ist
süßer sind
was du nicht vergessen
nach
auch in diesen kämpfen
traditionellen einsparen
mit kartoffelknödel und natürlich mit
kleinen brüsten dass eine knusprige haut
des schweins
aber was immer ganz wichtig ist niemals
das nörgeln betrieb
soviel zum bayerischen essen das waren
der bastion der kurz servus 40 bis zum
nächsten mal